we have a strong relationship from our
leadership to the leadership here and
straight through to the business
community we want to build on that we
think that obviously the United Kingdom
is going to look at developing trade
relationships after the exit after
brexit and we want to be a part of that
as part of the GCC so we think that
definitely there's lots of room for
growth and and we're here specifically
at a very high-level delegation to
engage with the government in the United
Kingdom and also the business community
all of the Gulf states the GCC countries
are looking to attract inward
investments one of the main selling
points of Bahrain a couple of selling
points number one I would say we offer a
hundred percent ownership so a very
liberal ownership regime where only 2%
of our business activities are
restricted to national ownership so 98%
are open to foreign ownership so are
very liberal and and investors like that
they don't have to take a partner they
can invest on their own I'd say the
second element is cost of doing business
we estimate that Bahrain is about 40 to
30 percent cheaper whether it is
accommodation its office rent and so
forth
whether it's industry or financial
sector then neighboring cities so I
that's a second attracting factor third
as I say and if everybody will say
strategic location but if you look at
the GCC 50% of the 1.5 trillion dollar
GDP in that region is in Saudi Arabia
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia and so
Bahrain is really 30 minutes away from
the Eastern Province so a lot of
corporates besides choosing to locate in
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia choose
behind as a port of call and very close
to accessing Aramco or even real so that
proximity and I'd say the fourth element
is this is a human talent the skill
level we have a very high participation
of our local workforce we've seen
companies who unlike in other areas
would locate them behind and be able to
employ 50 60 70 percent of their
workforce from locals and what would you
say to those people who say well
Bahrain's got a bit of a reputation for
human rights don't really want to go
there well I'm an economist I'm not a
politician
I would say come visit the country judge
for yourself the fact that we have major
corporates coming to behind like Amazon
Web Services like da ciao
these are corporates that have chosen
the country not to do a slip service but
actually because they see the merits of
our economic strategy and frankly the
openness of the country so I always
invite people to see for themselves why
is it so important a few to diversify
the economy away from oil and gas well
you know oil is now at 50 $60 a lot of
there was a period where we saw $100 oil
and governments were used to that level
of spending at $100 oil the view I think
shared by all the countries in the GCC
is that may not come back for a long
while some will say never but so you
have to adapt to a new reality in which
it's a lower oil price but just have to
shrink and if you are dependent on just
the oil industry you'll see no growth
for the foreseeable future so you have
to diversify to have different engines
of growth behind by virtue of having
less oil than the neighbors started this
way back in the 70s
so today 80% of our GDP is not reliant
on oil we only have 20% of our GDP
reliant on oil it's served us well